today is giving day and the red cross
knows las vegas doesn't disappoint
christian is live at the sahara west
library this afternoon to explain
exactly how far your blood donation
can go hi christian
hey kirsten will red cross volunteers
have been very busy today helping
nevadans who are coming out
to donate blood because they understand
how important it is now
blood donations are crucial right now
according to the red cross
because it saves lives just ask iris
ayres who has had
76 blood transfusions
in her ongoing battle with cancer i'm
blessed i'm still here
it's been seven long years of treatments
and surgeries for iris
air a life-changing moment she says
started when her doctor told her
she had cancer you're in and out of the
hospital i developed multiple
disabilities
for my cancer i was diagnosed with
ovarian cancer stage 3c
said it was late stage cancer which
many don't survive after the second year
but she did however it's a daily fight
for the single mother of three
her body is still healing from the
chemotherapy it's
been a rough ride in and out now
i have my bone marrow suppressed so i
have to get weekly labs
to check all my counts to see especially
if my hemoglobin is low
then another scare for iris the pandemic
how do i get to the doctors am i
able to go get testing am i able to
follow up with care
what do i do and how do i stay out of
the hospital i don't want to get sick
so there was many precautions that we
had to take
video calls were crucial to stay
connected with her 20 doctors
and so was blood and the donations she
relies on from the las vegas community
it's kept me alive
you know without those donations any
other treatments that i've had in the
care
i wouldn't really be here today
well iris is truly a fighter on top of
her treatment she has become an
ambassador for ovarian cancer
and has even started a group called iris
hope for ovarian cancer remarkable human
being
and a true fighter who is still alive
thanks to blood donations
from nevadans now coming up i'm going to
explain a little bit more about who can
donate and where you can donate
all that coming up in our later editions
of eight news now for now kirsten
i'll send it back over to you all right
we'll check back with you shortly thank
you christian